now to a story breaking overnight the
FBI is searching for a searching for a
fugitive a former top aide to Maryland's
ex-governor that has come to a sudden
and shocking end Scott McFarland is
following the story for us good morning
to you Scott Natalie good morning to you
not much is known about the
circumstances of the confrontation just
yet the FBI is investigating the agents
found Roy McGrath in Knoxville Tennessee
yesterday three weeks after he failed to
appear in court on fraud charges there
was a shooting McGrath was killed and
video from the scene shows a car window
that appears to be shattered from
gunfire McGrath was named then Maryland
governor Larry Hogan's Chief of Staff in
2020 and he resigned almost three months
later amid allegations he'd unlawfully
obtained hundreds of thousands of
dollars from a Maryland state agency he
was indicted in 2021 facing federal
fraud and embezzlement charges he
allegedly provided a memo saying Hogan
approved a more than two hundred
thousand dollar severance pay payment
after McGrath left a previous state
agency to become the governor's chief of
staff in a statement McGrath's attorney
called it a tragic ending and said
McGrath never wavered about his
innocence Hogan issued a statement
saying in part we are praying for Mr
McGrath's family and loved ones Nate
Scott thank you and Nash